a scene becoming more common here
funerals for high ranking Iranian
officials their bodies arriving from
Syria after being killed in Israeli air
strike this is the coffin of general
sadak
omad who was the head of the
intelligence unit of Iranian K forces in
Syria his wife is angry but not only at
Israel way before this we should have
had the ability and the power so that
the enemy cannot identify our forces and
attack them I wish we also had this
power to attack
Israel this sentiment is shared by many
Iranians here they believe their
government should not restrain itself
and retaliate with equal
force the most important the best
response to give is to give a hard
Revenge very soon and confront them and
to destroy their bases in the
region the Israeli attack that killed
five key Iranian intelligence figures in
Damascus on Saturday is a huge blow many
believe it could significantly reduce
Iran's capability to coordinate Regional
activities the Iranian government is
promising
Revenge Crimes by the usurping Zionist
regime against the Iranian government
and Nation have never gone and will not
go without penalty the Islamic Republic
of Iran will respond to the Crimes by
the Israeli regime in its own
way so far Iran has avoided a direct
military confrontation with Israel its
response is being conducted through what
Iran calls the exess of resistance
paramilitary groups in Syria Iraq
Lebanon and
Yemen there's a rising discontent among
Iranians here they say their
government's response is not adequate
and won't deter Israel from attacking
more Iranian assets but Iranian
officials believe if its responses are
not measured it could mean a war not
only with Israel but with the United
States of America RAR Al jazer
tan make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer